[Music]
hey there friends Drex here from Drex
Factor po sharing with you the love of
Po spinning and flowarts to benefit your
body and brain and today I am in the
dance studio cuz I am here to teach you
some BAS sick POI dance steps namely
something I like to refer to as a Gad
but before we dive in I just want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyate ha light toys spinballs
and Ultra for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these awesome companies
and the work that they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- business friend of
the channel Becca Becken thank you so
very much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission cool so gads are a
fairly easy way to add some footwork
into even the most basic po tricks we
can also add some intermediate and
advanced tricks to them as well but the
good news is is that this is a technique
that is going to work for you no matter
what your skill level is so let's go
check it out all right so first and
foremost what exactly is igad well in
classical technique igad would be me
taking a moment where I Playa and jump
out with one foot pointing in the
direction I want to go in and when I do
that leap I head on over to the side uh
Gad is French for Glide and the idea is
to use this movement to Glide across the
stage like so the version that I'm doing
is much more of a movement that kind of
keeps you in more or less one place on
the stage and just switches which foot
is forward and which is back creates a
really interesting silhouette when you
land on either side it has a lot in
common with uh a Jenga in capoa the
biggest difference being that as you're
performing a Jenga you want to try and
keep your uh hips more or less Square
facing off against your opponent whereas
with this I'm kind of leaning into
twisting up my body a wee bit just to
kind of create a more interesting
silhouette as I'm going back and forth
here if those of you out there who are
ballet nerds uh are not exactly feeling
my use of the word Gad here believe me I
totally understand if there is another
word that you think would be a better
fit please leave me a message down in
the comments and let me know but for
right now let's work with this all right
so to start with I'm going to go ahead
and do what would be kind of like a deep
fifth in uh in ballet or modern dance
where I've got my left foot in front of
me and my foot is kind of pointed off to
an angle and then my right foot is kind
of drifting off behind it the whole
point of this is to kind of create a
little bit of negative space here
between my feet as I'm facing my
audience from here I'm going to go ahead
and step out with my right foot and then
I'm going to step back behind my right
foot with my left again I'm going to
kind of twist myself up a little bit
here but it's going to create that
negative space between my legs that I'm
really looking for here so the pattern
would be step out with the left step
behind with the right step out with the
right step behind with the left note
that as I'm doing this I'm always
Landing in a place where my front foot
is in a paa that is it's slightly bent
and whichever foot is behind me is more
or less straight and if you want to go
for some extra points here you can point
that toe whenever you land to really
really emphasize that rear leg it's up
to you though all right so obvious
question why would we do such a thing
well I think it spices up a lot of Po
moves that involve moving back and forth
across Ross our body like so this right
here is a waist strap this involves just
taking a 3B weave from one side of the
body to the other from a forwards weave
to a reverse weave normally when we do
this we're traveling from our far right
side to our far left side our body
remains more or less static and unmoving
as this happens but something really
interesting can happen if I make a
different Choice like say when I switch
to that forwards weave I can come to
that starting position for the Gad here
and and then as I'm doing the turn to
the reverse weave I can step out and
Back Again step out with the Left Behind
with the right as I'm going to the
forwards weave step out with the right
behind with the left as I'm going to the
reverse weave I can even go straight
back and forth between the two and now a
PO trick that I think just a second ago
we would have thought of as pretty stock
becomes all the more interesting because
I've gotten my body involved and even
more than that I'm creating that really
nice silhouette with my body on either
side as I land and it turns out there's
a long list of other py tricks that have
this property in common with waist
straps off the top of my head we can say
go back and forth across the body in
Split time butterflies like this and
just like we did with our waist straps
we can take this into our Gad steps as
well check that
out in addition when we get to a point
where we can perform our caps going back
and forth across our body which bear in
mind this is essentially the same thing
as doing a hands together cap I'm just
taking it all the way over to either
side of my body and when it lands to
either side that's an opportunity for me
to shift my body back and forth as well
like
so there's also xan's Diamond when
performed in Split time opposites baked
into this pattern is the idea of taking
the hands and poy back and forth across
to either side of our body like so this
kind of builds in the transition back
and forth with the Gad steps like so
honestly this trick was kind of Built
For
[Music]
This in addition one of my favorite py
tricks to do this with is actually the
venerable stall Chaser this one takes
just a little bit more fine control over
the momentum of the POI than many of the
other POI tricks that I've showed you in
the course of this video but the good
news is it makes for a
fantastic companion piece to these glead
steps indeed that moment when the PO
points up at either side is kind of
Ideal for offsetting the foot that is
sticking straight back behind us as we
glead back and forth like
so
and then of course there are horizontal
Stacks which unlike the other poy tricks
on this list are almost always better
done with shorter POI and we want to go
through the pattern that was originally
set by Mel in his Tech POI video many
many years ago red pants that's this
right here which once again shows that
wonderful pattern that we've been
looking out for of going from side to
side so once again as we go from side to
side we can step in opposition to
[Music]
it so long and short basically any pyric
that moves back and forth across the
body you can kind of do this with and
one of the things that I really enjoy
about using Gad In this way is that they
kind of make you look at those py tricks
in a very very different fashion not
only do we get that great silhouette but
also in the process we kind of isolate
those tricks in space and it uh kind of
produces a different effect which is
always nice so let me show you a bunch
of these tricks with the gads and you
can mix and match with whichever ones
you
[Music]
like
do
[Music]
you do
you do you care
[Music]
cool so those are just a few of the
possibilities that are available out
there please play around with these and
see what you find see if you discover
Port Trix that I haven't considered that
work with these and of course if you're
a dancer let me know what you think of
my use of the term Gad for this move
back and forth and if there's a better
term that I can use in the meantime if
you do use these go ahead and post video
of yourself uh go ahead and tag me I am
Drex Factor on Instagram and Tik Tok and
I would love to see your hard work what
are some of your favorite po dance steps
leave me a comment and let me know and
don't forget to like share and subscribe
to help other people find this video and
to help my channel grow
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
the help of my awesome supporters on
patreon in particular I would like to
give a shout out to my flow patrons who
are listed on screen right now if you
dig these videos that I create there's a
great way that you can ensure that I
produce more of them in the future and
that is signing up to support me on
patreon a lot of the things that I have
to do in order to make income happen
take me away from producing videos on a
regular basis so if you want to see more
highquality videos like this one go
ahead and sign up over at
patreon.com factor pooy and help me
ensure that I can keep on making awesome
videos to teach boy to people all over
the world please and thank you and if
you dug this video on glads you might
also like a video that I put together on
shenet which are a similar kind of
footwork that involves taking you along
in a straight line I'll go ahead and
link to that video down in the
description as well as up here on screen
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon peace